Christina starts off this hour in
Atlanta
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
Christina hi Dave thank you so much for
taking my call
sure what's up well first of all I
wanted to thank you as a kid my mom used
to make us sit and listen to your show
on the way home from school and as an
adult I come back and we are on step two
baby step two we've already paid off
seven thousand dollars of debt and we
still have probably about thirty
thousand dollars left but last night I
was able to get my husband on board yes
the issue is is that my husband's
brother my brother-in-law he just
brought his wife over from a different
country they just got married December
1st and he has spent every penny of his
savings on her mainly before he even
brought her over
he had thirty five thousand dollars
saved ups and in two years he paid for
her apartment a master's degree her
medical bills a phone and a laptop floor
and all the lawyers and legal bills and
basically he has like two thousand
dollars left in his savings he's also
making thirty five thousand dollars a
year and that is their only income he's
living in his mom's house
and now she is very upset because she
thought that she was going to be taken
care of by him and so they're both
coming from different sides asking for
advice from me and my first thought was
oh boy what would a good old Uncle Dave
say so what he's supposed to take care
of his mother ain't supposed to take
care of his boy he brought his wife over
from a different country yeah so
well I understand he lives in his
mother's house and so the disagreement
is what he wants to be she wants him to
be more independent she wants to have a
place of their own but he doesn't have
the money for it the new one and so yes
okay well they make $35,000 a year right
yes
and when's she going to work we're
really not sure she in her home country
she was a psychologist she had the
certification and she now has to get
recertified in the United States in
order to continue that and she that work
is something else while that's happening
though yeah and she's she's been very
stubborn like right now they're not even
living together and he's giving her all
these different options on him you know
we're married I'm sorry why are they not
living together you know what they just
got married yes Wow so he's he's been
taken to the cleaners with a mail-order
brides what's happened pretty much but
her her family is actually here she does
have family members that live right next
door to my parents in law which is
helping that way and the family is very
much so so your question is why I mean I
mean this guy has marriage trouble and
it sounds like he's been scammed so how
are you gonna help him I don't think you
can't help him figure out how they can
how he can make her happy
and change they can't make her happy
we've already figured out what makes her
happy give her everything she wants and
then some and that's called princess
syndrome so no you can't you can't make
a princess happy princesses have to grow
up and become women so what would I have
to tell her just put on our big girl
don't tell her anything she didn't askin
you
she was actually she'd she lent me a
message together yeah and that's the
other thing is that she's she doesn't
speak any English so we have to speak
through Google Translate for everything
and she's she's having a hard time
coping with that fact as well so this is
no there's nothing in this whole story
that's going well um I I don't know I
mean I if she wants my opinion then
she's going to live with her husband and
she's going to get a job and we're gonna
put on her big-girl pants and quit
asking for so much crap because we live
with broke people now okay that's you
know that's the answer isn't it I mean
don't you think yeah and I I kind of
told her that I tried to I don't think
she's going to hear it no don't you
really want your opinion okay you listen
this show you get people on here all the
time they call me and they don't really
want my opinion they want my endorsement
of their stupidity you know and that's
what this chick is looking for she wants
you to go take her side and her
passive-aggressive way is to ask your
opinion but um no if you wanted my
opinion you shouldn't have you didn't
want my opinion you shouldn't ask
because I'm an expert on my opinion you
know so that's that's what you do that I
don't I mean if I were you I'd be very
kind but very firm and just say if you
ask me what I think and if I were in
your shoes here's what I would do I
think it's important that a husband and
wife live in the same home and I think
it's very important that you guys get a
little cheap apartment and get out from
under all the in-laws and all this other
stuff and I think you need to get a job
and I think the need to you need to get
on a budget but if you're not really
asking my opinion and I'm out you
obviously won't do any of that so it's
up to you though kiddo
I mean that's that's what I would say to
her you you just one of the things you
figure out as you get older is you
really can't make people do anything
they just have to decide to do stuff and
a lot of times you want them to win more
than they want to win in different areas
of their life I've had friends that were
addicts and you know they wanted cocaine
more than they wanted a good life and
you can't make them want the good life
and drop the cocaine you can't make
people do that but they can
beside the human we humans are given the
dignity by God to just decide to change
ready-set-go
you can just decide and then amazing you
ever met somebody just quit smoking yeah
they just decided they know patch no
nothing I just quit
no friend of mine just quit drinking
you know just quit after years of being
a drunk he just quit you know just just
like that and sometimes they have a you
know an experience with God that helps
them do that gives them the power to do
that but you can just decide I'm gonna
quit you know and what usually
precipitates that in all of our lives
folks is that what we we come to this
aha moment where we go what I'm doing
it's not working I'm gonna have to
change this and you have that aha moment
and then you're ready to go
but you just you have the dignity to
decide to change today and everyone's
got that dignity but we don't get to
tell other people how to do it or when
to do it I can't make you behave even if
I love you this is the Dave Ramsey show